if you design a product that doesn't fit
with tsmc you miss your biggest customer
and what that means is that if you want
to replicate tsmc you've got to
replicate the scale and the scale is
very very expensive to replicate so tsmc
is going to spend this year between 30
and $40 billion building new chip making
facilities that's roughly as much as the
US chips Act is going to spend over the
next 5 years so the US government wants
to build a chip industry it's going to
spend in 5 years what tsmc spends every
single year and that just shows the
level of difficulty in trying to build
up that scale outside of tsmc and tsmc
hasn't been investing that much for just
one year it's been investing huge sums
for the past 30 years which is why it's
got more capacity to produce not only
the most Cutting Edge chips but also
less Cutting Edge chips than anyone else